للمزيد انضم الينا من بلده رميش جنوبي
لبنان مدير مكتب الجزيره مازن ابراهيم كما
تنضم الينا من الجليل الاعلى مراسله
الجزيره فاطمه خمايسي اهلا بكم ابدا مع
مازن وفي ظل زياره مسؤول السياسات
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي لبيروت
ودعمه لفكره عدم تصعيد الصراع نلحظ تزايدا
في الاستهدافات والاستهداف النوعيه من قبل
حزب الله في شمال
اسرائيل
تماما عبد السلام الجبهه اليوم كانت
مشتعله على على المستوى العسكري الميداني
المباشر وايضا كان هنالك رسائل ذات دلاله
واهميه كبيره على المستوى السياسي من خلال
زياره جوزيف بوريل الى بيروت ولقائه ليس
فقط المسؤولين السياسيين على مستوى رئاسه
الحكومه ورئيس البرلمان ولكن ايضا لقاء مع
وفد من حزب الله ورسائل متبادله بين
الطرفين على المستوى الميداني كما ذكرت
العمليه كانت نوعيه التي نفذها حزب الله
صحيح انه نفذ اليوم نحو سبع عمليات ولكن
الابرز كانت ميرون تلك القاعده العسكريه
التي توصف بانها عيون اسرائيل على لبنان
وعلى كامل ساحل البحر الابيض المتوسط
وتحديدا لبنان سوريا تركيا مرورا بجزيره
قبرص وايضا شرق المتوسط هذه القاع
العسكريه الكبيره التي توصف بانها اداه
تجسس ورصد واستطلاع وتحكم بكل العمليات
العسكريه الجويه التي تحصل في هذه المنطقه
من لبنان وصولا الى تركيا وعلى طول هذا
الخط الساحلي تم توجيه الضربات لها بشكل
واضح مركز ووفق بعض المصادر افادتني بان
الصواريخ التي تم اطلاقها لم تكن من نوع
الصواريخ العشوائيه بمعنى انها لم تكن
مجرد اطلاقات من صواريخ كاتيوشا او جراد
ولكن تم استخدام انواع من الصواريخ
الموجهه والدقيقه كي تصيب تلك المرا
المراصد التي تمتاز بها هذه القاعده
العسكريه التي توجه كل العمليات الجويه
ومن هنا استهداف هذه القاعده وربطها
باغتيال الشيخ صالح العاروري ترتبط بشكل
اساسي بان عمليه الاغتيال تمت من خلال
طائرات حربيه وصواريخ موجهه من المقاتلات
الحربيه واستهداف هذه القاعده على بعد
اكثر من 8 كيلومترات من الحدود اللبنانيه
وكونها تختص بالعمليات العسكريه الجويه
فان هذا الامر كان يحمل دلاله هنا لابد من
الاشاره عبد السلام الى ان الرد
الاسرائيلي كان عنيفا ولاول مره تصل
الغارات الى قضاء صيدا عندما نتحدث عن
كوثر السياد هذه القريه في قضاء صيدا فان
الوصول الى هناك يعني كسرا اضافيا لكافه
الخطوط الحمراء التي كانت قد وضعت قبيل
الحرب وقبيل انطلاق هذه المواجهات في
الثامن من اكتوبر وارسي بعد عدوان عام
2006 مجموعه كبيره من الغارات الجويه على
اكثر من قريه اكثر من برده ولكن ابرزها
استهداف قضاء صيده وايضا استهداف جنوبي
مدينه صور بعجاله على موضوع السياسي جوزيف
بوريل الذي التقى برئيس الحكومه ورئيس
البرلمان وحمل رساله تدعو الى وقف التصعيد
كان له لقاء لافت نحن نتحدث عن راس
الدبلوماسيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي عن مسؤول
السياسات الخارجيه وقد طقى رئيس كتله
النيابيه لحزب الله محمد رعد بالاضافه الى
وفد من الحزب وهذا الامر لافت على المستوى
هذه هذا الموقع
الذي يقوم به ويمثله بوريل وبالتالي
الرسائل وفق المصادر الحكوميه التي
افادتني بان ضمن هذه الرسائل بوريل شدد
على ضروره عدم الانزلاق هنا على مستوى هذه
الجبهه الجنوبيه الى مزيد من التصعيد ولكن
وفق مصدر حكومي لبناني افادني بان حزب
الله بدوره ابلغ بوريل بانه غير منفتح
حاليا على نقاش اي تطور على مستوى الملف
اللبناني وعلى مستوى التطورات هنا في هذه
الجبهه الجنوبيه قبل ان يتم وقف العدوان
الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه وبالتالي ضمن اي
حديث مرتقب حول تطبيق القرار
1701 من خلال الضغط الاوروبي الضغط
الامريكي وحركه امس هوستن الموفد الامريكي
الى تل ابيب والى المنطقه والدفع باتجاه
تطبيق هذا القرار بما يعني نم انسحاب قوات
حزب الله الى ما وراء خط النهر الليطاني
فان هذا الامر كان الرد واضح من حزب الله
لا يمكن ان نقبل باي كلام بالسياسه او
التفاوض او الحوار على مستوى جنوب لبنان
وعلى مستوى المف اللبناني قبل ان يتم وقف
العدوان الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه شكرا لك
مازن ابراهيم ماذا عن تقييم الجيش
الاسرائيلي للتصعيد على الجبهه الشماليه
فاطمه نعم هذا التقييم يعني ينع عكس على
الرد الاسرائيلي اتجاه هذه العمليات
الكبيره التي تم اطلاقها اليوم من الاراضي
اللبنانيه نتحدث عن عمليات متتاليه
ومتسارع اخرها كان قبل نحو ساعه من الان
اذ دوت صفارات الانذار في مواقع مختلفه في
الجليل الغربي ومن ثم تم الاعلان عن
اعتراض الدفاعات الجويه لمسيره بالقرب من
منطقه ايفن مناحم في الجليل الغربي طبعا
هذه ليست المسيره الاولى التي يتم
اعتراضها اليوم تم اعتراض ايضا مسيره اخرى
بالقرب من موقع عسكري في مرج اليوت ايضا
في الجليل الغربي وكنا نتحدث عن عمليات
متتاليه ومتسارع شنها حزب الله باتجاه
مواقع مختلفه على طول الشريط الحدودي
الفاصل مع لبنان الجيش الاسرائيلي بدوره
قام بالرد على هذه العمليات النوعيه والتي
استهدفت القاعده العسكريه التي تحدث عنها
مازن في ميرون وتحديدا تقع في موقع الجبل
الجرمق طبعا تم استهدافها باكثر من 40
صاروخ وفق بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي الجيش
قال بانه رد عبر شن سلسله غارات جويه
بعيده المدى وواسعه النطاق في مناطق
مختلفه في جنوب لبنان وقال بانه استهدف
مخازن للاسلحه نتحدث عن مخازن تحديدا
لصواريخ الارض جو في مناطق مختلفه في جنوب
لبنان وايضا مواقع عسكريه وبنى تحتيه
ومنصات لاطلاق الصواريخ هذه الغارات
الجويه تمركزت في مواقع مح دد اعلن عنها
الجيش الاسرائيلي في بيانه الاخير الا وهي
منطقه عيتا الشعب راميه وميس الجبل وا
منطقه الخيام وايضا كان هنالك مناطق اخرى
قام باستهداف الجيش الاسرائيلي سواء عبر
السلاح الجو وايضا عبر المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه وكنا ايضا قد شاهدنا خلال
اليوم القاء قنابل فسفوريه في مناطق
مختلفه في البلدات الحدوديه اللبنانيه
وهذا ياتي في اطار الرد الاسرائيلي على
سلسله العمليات التي استهدفت الجليل
الغربي والجليل الاعلى نتحدث عن دوي
صفارات الانذار في اكثر من 90 موقع صباح
هذا اليوم وايضا تم رصد عده صواريخ سقطت
بالقرب من كريات شموني نتحدث عن سقوط
اربعه صواريخ في تلك المنطقه وايضا
استهداف موقع عسكري في بلده المطله
استهداف ايضا في بلده افيفيم في الجليل
الغربي ودو فيف ومناطق اخرى عديده ولكن في
جميع هذه الحوادث لم يتم الاعلان عن اي
اصابات او اضرار في المقابل الجيش قام
بالرد على ما يقول انها مصادر هذه
الصواريخ وقام ايضا باستهداف خلايا يقول
بانها تابعه لحزب الله وكانت مسؤوله عن
تنفيذ هذه العمليات الصاروخيه لذلك
بالمجمل كنا امام تطورات ميدانيه جدا مهمه
وجدا لافته وهذا جميعه كله يقع ضمن الرد
الاولي من قبل حزب الله على عمليه استهداف
صالح العاروري وبالتالي سوف نرى ما ستحمله
الايام من ردود اخرى مرتقبه لحزب الله
وتنعكس بطبيعه الحال على حاله التاهب
الميداني الجيش الاسرائيلي شكرا جزيلا لك
فاطمه خمايسي من الجليل الا